- [Instructor] We've
already spent some time
looking at the ideal gas
law, and also thinking about
scenarios where things might diverge
from what at least the
ideal gas law might predict.
And what we're going to do in this video
is dig a little bit deeper into scenarios
where we might diverge a little bit
from the ideal gas law, or
maybe I guess, a lot of it
in certain situations.
So I have three scenarios here.
This first scenario right over here,
I have a high temperature,
high temperature,
and I have a large volume.
And both of these are really important
because when we think
about when we get close
to being ideal, that
situation's where the volume
of the particles themselves
are negligible to the volume
of the container.
And at least here, looks
like that might be the case
'cause we're dealing
with a very large volume.
Even this isn't drawn to scale.
I just drew the particles this size
just so that you could see them.
And high temperature,
that helps us realize
that well maybe the
intermolecular interactions
or attractions between the particles
aren't going to be that significant.
And so in a high temperature,
large volume scenario,
this might be pretty close to ideal.
Now it's not gonna be perfectly ideal
because real gases have some volume,
and they do have some
intermolecular interactions.
But now let's change
things up a little bit.
Let's now move to the same volume.
So we're still dealing
with a large volume.
But let's lower the temperature.
So low temperature.
And we can see because
temperature is proportional
to average kinetic
energy of the particles,
that here, these arrows on
average are a little bit smaller.
And let's say we lower the temperature
close to the condensation point.
Remember, the condensation point of a gas,
that's a situation where
the molecules are attracting
each other, and even starting
to clump up together.
They're starting to, if
we're thinking about say,
water vapors, they're starting
to get into little droplets
of liquid water, because
they're getting so attracted
to each other.
So in this situation,
where we have just
lowered the temperature,
the ideal gas law would already
predict that if you keep
everything else constant, that
the pressure would go down.
If we solve for pressure,
we would have P is equal to nRT over V.
So if you just lowered temperature,
the ideal gas law would already predict
that your pressure would be lower.
But in this situation with a real gas,
because we're close to
that condensation point,
these gases, these particles
are more and more attracted
to each other.
So they're less likely
to bump into the sides
of the container, or if they do,
they're going to do it with less vigor.
So in this situation for a real gas,
because of the intermolecular attraction
between the particles,
you would actually have
a lower pressure than even the
ideal gas law would predict.
Ideal gas law would already predict
that if you lower the temperature,
pressure would go down.
But you would see that a
real gas in this scenario,
P, even lower, even lower for a real gas.
Now let's go to another scenario.
Let's go to a scenario where
we keep the high temperature
that we had in the original scenario,
but now we have a small
volume, small volume.
Maybe this top of the
container is a piston,
and we push it down like this.
Well the ideal gas law, if
we just solve for P again,
P is equal to nRT over V.
It would already predict
that if you decrease the denominator here,
that's going to increase the
value of the entire expression.
So it would already
predict that you would have
a higher pressure, that
the particles will bounce
into the sides of the
container more frequently,
and with more vigor.
But if we have a really small
volume of the container,
we no longer can assume that the volume
of the particles themselves
are going to be negligible
compared to the volume of the container.
And so the effective
volume, to move around in
is even lower than we're
seeing in this equation.
So these particles have even
less space to bounce around in
because they take up some of the space.
So they're going to bounce
off the sides of the container
more frequently and even more vigor.
So here, pressure even
higher for a real gas
than what is predicted
by the ideal gas law.